The next thing we need to cover is something called the Lie Factor.
The lie-factor is a metric that was created by Edward Tufte
that describes the integrity of a graphic, or
how well a graphic actually represents its underlying data.
You compute the lie-factor by dividing the size of the effect,
as shown in the graphic, by the size of the effect shown in the data.
Typically, we want the lie-factor to be within 0.95 and 1.05.
A lie-factor of one is ideal, because we would have the exact same
effect shown in the graphic as it is in the data.
But due to some jitter with we how we represent data in graphical form,
having a lie-factor within this range is typically seen as very good.
A visualization with a lie-factor in this range has high integrity, and
is representing the data accurately.
Now that we know what lie-factor is, how do we calculate it?
So, let's recall that lie factor measures the difference between
the effect shown in the graphic and the effect seen in the data.
First, let's look at how we would calculate the size of the effect
shown in the graphic.
First we'll find the difference by subtracting the second value
from the first value seen in the graphic.
Then we'll compute the change by dividing by the first value.
We'll need to add absolute value bars here, to account for negative change.
Multiplying this by 100 gives us the change as a percentage.
We apply this method toward the graphic and
the data and then divide this entire quantity to get our overall y factor.